an ancient arena for ocean giants
in one corner enormous yellow fin tuna
nearly twice the length of a man
weighing over 800 pounds one of the
fastest fish in the ocean
in the other corner
sharks
thousands of them
crushing teeth
lightning fast speed
and street gang numbers
but the tuna remained one step ahead
this is
shark versus tuna
some call it the rock
a jurassic park
lost in the south atlantic ocean
[Music]
over a thousand miles from land in any
direction
this is ascension island
darwin's best kept secret
everything that lives here
or stops here is either hunter
or hunted
[Music]
ascension plays host to one of nature's
greatest showdowns
thousands of the ocean's most deadly
predators arrive from far and wide to
fight it out in a high-stakes battle
royale
[Music]
schools of jacks dominate the drop-offs
thousands of green turtles come here
annually to nest on the sandy beaches
and swarms of huge predatory fish
like barracuda marlin and wahoo lurk in
the open water
but no one is safe
except maybe this
enormous yellow fin tuna
this superfish normally lives life in
the desert of the open ocean where food
is scarce
but every easter
ascension island becomes an oasis for
giant tuna migrating across the atlantic
it's one of the largest concentrations
of yellowfin in the world
to get in and out of the rock alive you
must be big smart and fast
despite being near the top of the food
chain tuna are a favorite meal for
sharks if they can catch them
so not only must the yellowfin be an
exceptional predator it must be a wily
escape artist too
the average yellowfin is by no means
small but ascension is home to giants
nearly twice the length of a man
and as heavy as a horse
this is one of the fastest fish in the
ocean
even the u.s navy studied it as a model
for submersible drones
built for speed the tuna's gills are
over 30 times larger than other fish its
size to draw in more oxygen
and its heart is ten times bigger with a
faster heartbeat
like the great white shark the yellow
fin is warm-blooded which allows it to
swim faster for longer and exploit the
colder deeper waters where other
predators can't hunt
[Music]
little can keep up with or escape this
turbocharged fish
and their next feeding stop
is ascension island
the tuna's arrival acts like a dinner
bell
for some of the ocean's fiercest marine
predators
at this time of year the tuna are set to
run a gauntlet of sharks
and they aren't the only ones that want
a piece of the tuna
tales of ascension's big game fish
attract sports fishermen and trophy
hunters from all over the world
of all the fish they target here
the giant yellow fin is highly prized
some carry a twenty thousand dollar
paycheck
the wiley tuna doesn't take the bait
this time
an 8-foot wahoo does
[Music]
below the surface the fish's struggles
are a call to arms
[Music]
at ascension everyone's hungry
[Music]
[Music]
so
in under a minute a 120 pound wahoo is
[Music]
obliterated they try to eat everything
even the bony head
[Music]
with the sharks distracted in frenzy the
tuna escape
but the battle lines are drawn
these sharks mean business
and there are thousands of them
like the tuna sharks ride the south
atlantic current to ascension in
terrifying numbers
tigers hammerheads and mako to the
ever-increasing sightings of galapagos
sharks
each is locked in an evolutionary arms
race with the tuna
and right now
no one knows who's winning
[Music]
the sharks patrol the beaches
the rock is under siege
there is an abundance of prey here
but like the fisherman the shark's holy
grail is the giant yellow fin
after traveling thousands of miles to
get here these sharks are desperate to
replenish their reserves
[Music]
tuna are jam-packed with some of the
richest fattiest meat in the ocean
and an 800 pound yellow fin is the
jackpot
but how on earth will these sharks
successfully catch and kill such
formidable prey
yellowfin tuna are unbelievably fast
powerful predators
and for a shark incredibly hard to catch
there are only a handful of contenders
up for the tuna challenge
to hunt these superfish you need
extraordinary predatory powers
meet the resident bad boy
the galapagos shark
ascension is their local hunting ground
and unlike the tuna and migrant sharks
they know this terrain like the backs of
their hands
most of them grew up here
learning to hunt in the shallow
nurseries
and in the last two years galapagos
sightings have increased dramatically
despite reaching 12 feet in length this
welterweight is only half the size of
the giant yellow fin
its streamlined and slender frame does
give this shark agility and speed like
the tuna
but like its cousin the tiger shark the
galapagos has more powerful jaws and
sharper serrated teeth
this allows for a highly varied diet
from bony fish and iguanas to sea lions
and even each other
but here at ascension yellowfin remain a
number one prize
[Music]
oily prey like tuna leaves a scent
signature up to two miles away
in the open blue water this galapagos
shark's incredible sense of smell could
give it the edge
almost two-thirds of their brain is
dedicated to smell
the nostrils or nairs are not required
for breathing
all the better to smell you with
10 000 times better than humans
where the galapagos shark matches the
tuna is in
numbers most sharks hunt alone
but the galapagos move in a mob
a veritable street gang of aggression
they investigate anything that may
potentially become prey
like a school of piranhas competition
drives them to frenzy
the galapagos may be fast agile and
aggressive
and they may have the numbers
but one-on-one they hardly stand a
chance
in the open ocean the giant tuna are
just too fast
too strong
and too big
this underdog would have to do something
spectacular to sink its teeth into one
to win a giant tuna you need to put more
on the table
a heavyweight enters the ring
the tiger shark
like its namesake its striped camouflage
allows the tiger to silently stalk prey
virtually undetected
their stripes may fade with age but
killer instincts and voracious appetites
stay with them for life
this undisputed heavyweight weighs
nearly four times more than the giant
tuna
and reaches over half the length of a
school bus
it has an arsenal of weaponry
to track
hunt and devour massive prey
[Music]
these super fast yellow fins are no easy
target
so the tiger shark will be on the
lookout for struggling young injured and
old fish
[Music]
a large school offers safety in numbers
both to hunt and to keep a lookout
but you can't hide from the tiger shark
two powerful internal ears in its
forehead pick up sound from several
miles away
while specialized reflective plates in
the eyes provide night vision in low
light
and even if the tiger can't see
smell or hear its prey
it can still feel them
tracing the shark's body is a thin
fluid-filled tube known as the lateral
line
like an ear it's lined with millions of
tiny hairs that react to any movement in
the water
the kind of movement created by feeding
tunas
this built-in tracking device helps
distinguish large from small prey
individual from school as well as the
distance and speed of its target
[Music]
once the tiger gets within range the
tuna doesn't stand a chance
this juggernaut has the power to crush a
car
[Music]
it can eat anything
from dolphins rays and seals
to whatever falls into the water
like birds trash and even people
the tiger shark is responsible for the
most attacks against humans
second only to the great white
this indiscriminate diet is largely
thanks to their highly specialized teeth
this turtle
which most likely succumbed to the
exhaustion of nesting
may be too tough for most sharks but for
the tiger it's a welcome meal
unlike other sharks that have a variety
of teeth the tigers are almost identical
each working like a circular saw
the highly serrated edge cuts and slices
through flesh
and the large razor sharp cusp hacks
through bone and shell
while the curved shape helps brace each
tooth against the powerful bite
the tiger pulverizes the turtle's bones
and shell to unlock marrow proteins and
fats
it's all tasty nutrition
if you've got the stomach for it
the tiger's oversized gut is lined with
a muscular wall
nearly three times thicker than other
sharks
and filled with enough acid to handle a
license plate
the giant yellow fin may be a prize
catch
but this scavenger can fill up on any
available food source it finds at
ascension
yet despite all its raw power the tiger
shark isn't fast enough to catch a
healthy tuna
this tank can only swim slightly faster
than an iceberg
even at its top speed of 20 miles per
hour it doesn't have the stamina to keep
up
to catch these fish you need real speed
and there is only one shark fast enough
[Music]
as well as numbers the tuna also have
exceptional speed and endurance
thanks to their fatigue resistant
muscles the giant tuna could finish the
boston marathon in just over 30 minutes
maxing out at up to 47 miles per hour as
fast as an american quarter horse
maneuvering at such pace requires
military precision
the tuna's bright yellow finlets help
reduce turbulence
while its fins retract into modified
grooves to minimize drag
and unlike any other creature the tuna
uses its lymphatic system like
hydraulics to stiffen its fins which
allows for sharp turns when chasing prey
life at super speed requires fuel
lots of it
squid mackerel octopus and even other
tuna are all on the menu
to satisfy this insatiable hunger the
yellowfins swim nearly 20 miles a day in
search of large schools of prey
but here at ascension the food is on tap
they track prey by the smell of the oil
on its skin
and once spotted the attacks are so fast
if you blink you'll miss it
[Music]
like lions the tuna round up their prey
making it easier to pick
off as quickly as it began the frenzy is
over
[Music]
it takes a thief to catch a thief
so who better than the fastest shark in
the world
the short fin mako
this shark lives life in the fast lane
literally
unable to pump water over its gills
the mako must keep moving to stay alive
[Music]
in a 30-year lifetime this shark can
swim more than 15 times around the world
it's slightly smaller than the tiger
shark but every inch of this torpedo
from tip to tail is evolved for speed
as heavy as a grizzly
faster than a jackrabbit
[Music]
it roams the vast open ocean at
lightning speed in search of its
favorite prey
bison-sized tuna
like its name suggests the short fin
mako has short pointed fins which help
reduce drag and allow for sharp tight
turns like a fighter jet to counter the
tuna's evasive maneuvers
even its narrow pointed snout and long
recurved teeth are modified for hooking
prey on the go
one of the mako's key adaptations for
its incredible speed
is its metallic looking skin
very different than any other animal or
bony fish sharks are covered in
thousands of tiny teeth-like scales
hard as granite strong as steel yet
flexible like chain mail the mako's
scales are smaller and lighter than most
sharks modified for speed rather than
protection
each hydrodynamic scale is ridged to
channel water
which in turn reduces turbulence and
noise
this shark can freewheel at an
incredible 35 miles per hour in near
complete silence
but to catch giant tuna the mako must
swim faster than any other shark
the secret to its explosive speed is
hidden deep within its body
sharks like the tiger are powered by
swimming muscles that run along the
sides of their bodies producing a slow
snake-like movement
while in the mako and the tuna
these same muscles are positioned closer
to the backbone
they act like a pair of pistons
much like an engine for a speedboat
propeller
these muscles reduce the mako's lateral
movements and focus all the raw power
directly to its tail
even their hydrofoil tails are modified
for maximum speed
unlike most sharks the mako's upper lobe
is almost identical in size and shape to
the lower lobe
this allows them to catch more water
when swimming optimizing full
acceleration
[Music]
so the short fin mako has the raw speed
to ambush the giant tunas
but the yellow fin has a trump card
it's game on
two of the ocean's fastest predators are
locked in a battle of speed
the mako plays its final hand
this shark can raise its body
temperature 18 degrees above that of the
water
increasing its hunting abilities muscle
efficiency and power
the mako shifts up into turbo drive
closing the gap
but the tuna has a few tricks up its
sleeve too
in a surprise twist everything the mako
can do so can the tuna
through convergent evolution the yellow
fin is also optimized to hunt at speed
just like the mako the tuna's
torpedo-shaped body is also coated with
small scales to reduce drag and its
short pointed fins also allow for sharp
evasive maneuvers
the tuna also has modified swimming
muscles to minimize body movement
and provide maximum power to a similar
near-symmetrical tail
and like the mako the tuna can warm its
blood to turbocharge its muscles
mako meets its match
[Music]
on paper the mako has the speed but the
overwhelming numbers of tuna create
distraction in the chase
unable to lock onto a target the mako
steps off the gas
like houdini the tunas escape once again
and the mako
folds
[Music]
this elusive superfish gives the sharks
of ascension a run for their money
but there is one threat the tuna cannot
escape from
a predator that doesn't play by the
rules
man
although yellowfin are near threatened
they remain a highly prized catch both
commercially and for sport
anglers spear fishermen and trophy
hunters from all around the world
believe that giant yellowfin are pound
for pound the fastest and strongest of
all big game tunas
but it takes ingenuity patience and
sheer luck to land one
such a formidable predator has gained
the respect and honor of battle
and each year more and more fishermen
arrive at ascension stealing the tuna
from right under the shark's noses
it can take eons for animals to learn
new behaviors
but more intelligent creatures can adapt
much faster
sometimes within just a few generations
[Music]
one such species is the galapagos shark
experts believe these resourceful
predators have learned to make a crucial
connection between the giant tuna and
the fishing boats
the galapagos may not be as fast as the
mako or as strong as the tiger
but this dangerously smart predator has
a hunting hack
and they plan to use man to help them
out
man is a creature of habit and fishermen
always do the same thing every day
they head out at the same time
they use the same bait
and select the same lures
they trawl the same successful spots
targeting the exact fish that the sharks
yearn for
day after day the inquisitive galapagos
sharks take advantage of this monotony
and start to learn the patterns
[Music]
like a hive mind they begin to associate
triggers sight sounds and smells of
struggling fish
the hum of a boat motor the scent of
bait in the water or even the snap of a
spear gun's elastic means it's time to
feed
the sharks work out that 20 minutes
after a boat arrives a fish is usually
on the line
forget pavlov's dogs
meet pavlov's sharks
[Music]
some fishermen will do anything to cash
in on a yellow fin
and the bigger the risk the bigger the
reward
but entering these waters could cost you
your life
[Music]
miles out to sea this spear fisherman is
alone
or so he thinks
he baits the water to draw the yellow
fin up from the deep
[Music]
but this free food doesn't only attract
the tuna
several miles away a pack of hungry
galapagos smell it too
with chum in the water the diver knows
he only has a short window of
opportunity before the sharks find him
every minute he stays here
the more he puts his life at risk
[Music]
who will arrive first
tuna
[Music]
or sharks
[Music]
dark shapes appear below
[Music]
it's the yellow fin
and they're big
they won't hang around for long
should he risk
[Music]
one good-sized tuna could pay the bills
for a year
[Music]
the tuna may be big
but they're so fast he can't get a clean
shot
[Music]
the longer the diver stays in the water
the more chance the hunter may become
the hunted
[Music]
he lines up
a direct hit
the tuna dives
now he's fighting a 200 pound lump of
muscle
his second spear just seems to enrage
the powerful fish further
the more the yellow fin struggles the
clearer the signal is to the sharks
food is served
the spear fishermen must hurry
but this tuna shows no signs of tiring
too late
the first wave of galapagos arrives
they want the tuna and will happily go
through man to get it
[Music]
the more it struggles the more excited
the sharks become
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
the spear fisherman escapes with his
tuna
and his life
the hungry sharks are left with nothing
but the scraps of his bait bag
perhaps it was this distraction of free
food
or that only a handful of sharks arrived
that enabled the diver's lucky escape
the fishermen have yet to hook a giant
tuna
it's too dangerous to get back in the
water
the only safe way to catch one is from
the boat
could this be the opportunity the sharks
have been waiting for
for the galapagos it's double or nothing
[Music]
it's the end of july and the giant tuna
are here
these yellow fins are super fast
immensely strong and can grow to well
over 800 pounds making them even harder
to catch
they are what everyone wants
for man a giant yellow fin is worth
thousands of dollars and one of the
ultimate fishing trophies
for the sharks that traveled all the way
to ascension the giant tuna is their
meal ticket home
ascension is now the perfect storm of
predators
but who will win
the enormous tiger shark is just too
slow to step up to the plate
the mako may have supreme speed and
agility but so does the giant tuna
it's the galapagos mob that has the best
chance of a successful hunt
a shark is dangerous enough
but an intelligent shark is deadly
the galapagos is smart on its own
and here at ascension there are
thousands of them
this is their domain
and it's time to take it back
most flee and hide from the approaching
fishermen
but for the clever galapagos it's a
dinner bell
lures are rigged the lines are set it's
a waiting game for all
shapes appear in the deep
a giant tuna takes the bait
the dinner bell is ringing
it's like the wahoo massacre but this
meal is as big as some of the sharks
the giant yellowfin begins to tire
the first galapagos moves in
for the fishermen it's a race to get the
prize catch onto the safety of the boat
but the tuna is too strong
the galapagos start to swarm
one dominant shark gets the first taste
thick warm blood will attract the masses
covering the shark's snout are thousands
of what appear to be blackheads
but they're really like built-in
voltmeters picking up the minute
electrical signature and even the
heartbeat of prey
this sixth sense is the most acute
sensory system in the animal kingdom
the salt from the tuna's blood increases
the intensity of the electrical field
surrounding the fish
which is why a shark will continue to
target and attack only the injured
victim
excitement soon turns to frenzy
tuna is survival to the galapagos shark
[Music]
in less than a minute a 350-pound
fish
vanishes
the fishermen leave with nothing
but a broken line
the galapagos sharks rule the rock
[Music]
[Music]
you